ALL RIGHT, GRUELING.
HAPPY MONDAY, HAPPY MONDAY,
EVERYONE.
IT IS COLUMBUS DAY.
WHICH MEANS IT IS TIME FOR ♪ ♪
GREG STEEN CORNER.
WELCOME TO TEEN CORNER WHERE WE
DISCUSS THE HOTTEST TOPICS FOR
TODAY'S HOTTEST TEENS.
YOU MAY OR MAY NOT BE AWARE THAT
THERE'S A SHOW ON THIS NETWORK
THAT AIRS AT 5:00 P.M., AND GET
THIS IT'S CALLED "THE FIVE" HOW
LONG DID IT TAKE THEM TO COME UP
WITH THAT?
ALSO HAS FIVE PEOPLE, BUT
THURSDAY SOMETHING WAS SET ON
THE SHOW THAT IN THE WORDS OF
THE MEDIA SPARKED OUTRAGE.
I LET THAT DEFINITION, BECAUSE
IT'S ONE MEDIA OUTLET REPORTS ON
TWEETS THAT ANOTHER MEDIA OUTLET
REPORTED ON EARLIER.
THEY GOSSIP LIKE A GROUP OF
HIGH SCHOOL GIRLS SITTING
TOGETHER IN THE CALF.
IT'S NOT REPORTING, ITS
REPURPOSED THING, LIKE
GERALDO RIVERA DOES WITH FIVE
DEAD CATERPILLARS TO MAKE A
MUSTACHE.
CAN'T EVEN TELL, CAN YOU?
AMAZING.
SO WHAT WAS THE OFFENDING
OPINION ON "THE FIVE" LET'S FIND
OUT?
>> COLLEGE DOES NOT LOOK LIKE IT
IS FUN ANYMORE, HAVE YOU SEEN
HOW MISERABLE THE STUDENTS ARE,
THEY ARE UGLY FIND THEMSELVES
COMING TO SEE THEM ON TIKTOK,
THEY ARE OUT OF SHAPE, ASEXUAL,
THEY DON'T WANT, THEY ARE LIKE
REJECTING THE TRUTH AND BEAUTY,
THEY ALL LOOK LIKE REJECTS FROM
A LOONY BIN.
I WOULD STEER CLEAR OF COLLEGE
TOO.
WHO THE HELL DOES HE THINK HE
IS?
HE IS NOT A SPRING TRICK AGAIN,
NOT EVEN A SPRING ROLL, AND HIM
JUDGING THE LOOKS OF OTHER
PEOPLE SEEMS A LITTLE IRONIC ON
A SCALE OF 1-10, MAYBE HE IS A
9.4.
BUT LOOKING AT THEM MAY BE TWICE
BODY FAT.
SOME PEOPLE MIGHT FIND THEM
ATTRACTIVE, I DON'T KNOW.
HIS PIERCING BLUE EYES, THOSE
ROCK-HARD PACKS, GORGEOUS
SALT-AND-PEPPER HAIR.
IT'S NO WONDER THE JEALOUS MEDIA
POUNCED.
MY FAVORITE HEADLINE FOX NEWS
HOSTS 58 UNDER FIRE.
UNDER FIRE FOR BIZARRE
COMPLAINT, THE COLLEGE KIDS
AREN'T HOT ENOUGH.
THAT'S THE INDEPENDENT BRITISH
PAPER, BUT I AM OLD ENOUGH TO BE
THEIR PROFESSOR AND THEY ARE OLD
ENOUGH TO BE MY GIRLFRIEND.
BUT I AGREE, WHAT GREG GUTFELD
SAID WAS CALLOUS ESPECIALLY TO
THESE WRITERS WHO LET'S FACE IT
THEY ARE ALL POWWOWS.
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT YOUR
JOURNALIST LATELY?
WHAT A COLLECTION UP BEFORE
PICTURES.
THEY LOOK LIKE SOMETHING ELSE
MADE IN A LAB!
ON A SCALE OF 1-10, JOURNALISTS
WOULD BE AND NINE.
IN GERMAN THAT MEANS NO WILL, AS
I KNOW, I WOULD NEVER SLEEP WITH
YOU.
BUT THE ANGER WAS WORSE AMONG
THE BRITISH JOURNALISTS.
THEY ARE VERY SENSITIVE, AND I
DON'T BLAME THEM, YOU KNOW,
THERE HOTTEST WOMAN OVER THERE
IS HARRY STYLES.
AND THEIR TEETH ARE THE BEST
PART OF THEIR FACES.
I KNOW, I'M GLAD YOU AGREE WITH
ME.
THE TEACHERS UNION IS JUST A
COINCIDENCE, BUT THE PLANE, IT'S
JUST TERRIBLE, THE PLANE DON'T
PROTEST, BECAUSE HOW WOULD THE
CHANCE GO?
HEY, HEY,,, THE SKIN TAGS HAVE
GOT TO GO.
BUT I'VE ALWAYS BEEN THERE BY
THEIR SIDE, I WANT YOU TO LOOK
AT THIS PEOPLE OF TRUTH WRITTEN
IN 2007, IT'S LIKE 15 YEARS AGO.
IT'S NOW AVAILABLE IN PAPERBACK.
I DON'T KNOW.
AND ELAINE CHAPTER TITLED THE
UGLY HAVE NO GANDHI, I GO INTO
DEPTH ON HOW THE MOST
DISCRIMINATED GROUP OF PEOPLE
ARE NOT BLACK, HISPANIC,,,
TRANS, IT'S SO HOMELY, HAVING A
FACE LIKE JOY BEHAR, I KNOW.
[APPLAUSE]
I HOPE YOU ARE APPLAUDING HER
INSPIRATION FOR EVERYBODY AND A
BODY LIKE JOY BEHAR.
THE HOMELY OR GET FEWER JOB
OFFERS, FEWER DATES, AND NO
THANKS TO THOMAS EDISON, THEY
HAVE TO DEAL WITH LIGHTS.
[LAUGHTER]
THERE ARE LOADS OF STUDIES THAT
BEAR THAT OUT, AND IF I DID NOT
LIVE A REALLY COOL LIFE, I
WOULD'VE LOOKED THEM UP.
SO YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO TAKE
MY WORD FOR IT, SOMEONE THIS
GOOD LOOKING DOES NOT HAVE TO
LIVE.
BUT I WAS NOT ALWAYS THAT HOT.
I HAD TO PUT WORK INTO IT, I GO
TO THE GYM, I WATCH WHAT I EAT,
GROOM ALL THE PROBLEM AREAS.
TAKES FOUR MEN TELL WAX MY BODY
HAIR.
THREE TO HOLD ME DOWN AND ONE TO
VIDEOTAPE.
STILL, A DOZEN ARTICLES WERE
WRITTEN ABOUT GREG GUTFELD'S
COMMENTS, OTHER ARTICLES
INCOMPLETE BECAUSE THE AUTHORS
WERE CRYING TOO HARD TO COMPLETE
THEM.
NOW BESIDES THESE WRITERS, NO
ONE HAS ACTUALLY OFFENDED BY
THESE COMMENTS, THEY ARE JUST
REPORTING ON THE POSSIBILITY OF
OFFENSE, AND ALL OF THESE PIECES
NOTED GREG GUTFELD'S AGE WHICH
IS AGAIN 58 TO SUGGEST THAT THAT
AGE AND THIS KIND OF COMMENTARY
WOULD BE CREEPY, BUT IT
BACKFIRED INSTEAD OF EVERYONE
SAYING THAT OLD GUY IS GROSS IT
WAS HOLY CRAP, HOW COULD THAT
AMAZING LOOKING GUY BE 58,
THAT'S INSANE.
THEY ARE LIKE -- I KNOW.
[APPLAUSE]
JUST CLAP!
EVEN I SAW HIM AND I SAID,
WHATEVER HE IS DOING, SIGN ME
UP.
BUT I GET IT, BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT ARGUE THE POINT, THEY
BLAME THE HOT MESSENGER.
THAT HAS TO MAKE GUTFELD SMILE,
AND WHAT A BEAUTIFUL SMILE IT
IS, YOU CAN MELT THE ICICLES ON
BRIAN SALTERS [BLEEP].
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF HE HAS IT.
SO IF I WERE GUTFELD, I WOULD
TAKE A GOOD LOOK IN THE MIRROR
AND ENJOY THE VIEW.
AND AS FOR THE MEDIA, THAT GROUP
OF HOMELY COPYCATS WHO CONTINUE
TO BOTTOM FEED OFF OF THEIR OWN
RACK, I HOPE FOR OUR SAKE THEY
DO IT WITH A LIGHTS OUT.
[APPLAUSE]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS!
HE IS PRETTY VOCAL ABOUT WANTING
TO BE KATHY HOGLE, CONGRESSMAN
CANDIDATE LEE ZELDIN!
YES!
SHE'S HAD MORE SCOOPS THAN
MICHAEL MOORE AT BASKIN-ROBBINS,
LYDIA MOYNIHAN!
HIS LAUGH IS SO CONTAGIOUS THAT
IT OFTEN GETS MISTAKEN FOR
TUBERCULOSIS, WATCH ANY TIME,
OPINION EDITOR AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR CHARLIE HURT?
AND THIS MONTH HE HAS SWITCHED
HER PEPPER SPRAY TO PUMPKIN
SPICE, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR CAT
TIF.
NOW BEFORE I GET TO THE
SUPERFICIAL NATURE OF MY
MONOLOGUE I WANT TO ASK YOU, YOU
HAD A WILD NIGHT'S LAST NIGHTS,
YOU ARE INVOLVED IN SOME
GUNPLAY, HOW DID IT ALL HAPPEN,
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> CRAZY COMING YESTERDAY AROUND
2:20 IN THE AFTERNOON, AND WE
WERE IN A COLUMBUS PARADE IN THE
BRONX AND WE HAD JUST LEFT MY
DAUGHTER'S WHO WERE ACTUALLY
HERE TODAY, THEY WERE AT HOME
ALONE DOING HOMEWORK IN THE
KITCHEN TABLE AND ALSO GUNSHOTS
ERUPTED AND THEY WERE SCREAMING
AND THOUGHT THAT THESE PEOPLE
WERE ACTUALLY COMING INTO THE
HOUSE, THEY WERE SWIFT AND SMART
AND RAN UPSTAIRS AND LOCK
THEMSELVES IN THE BATHROOM AND
CALLED 911, ONE OF THE BULLETS
WAS FOUND ABOUT 30 FEET FROM
WHERE THEY WERE SITTING, THE TWO
PEOPLE WHO WERE SHOT WERE LAYING
DOWN ABOUT 10 FEET FROM WHERE
THEY WERE SITTING, IT WAS A
PRETTY WILD MOMENT, WE HAVE BEEN
RUNNING THIS CAMPAIGN WHERE WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT RISING
CRIME IN NEW YORK, I WAS NOT
EXPECTING THAT THE NEXT PRESS
CONFERENCE WAS GOING TO BE IN
FRONT OF CRIME SCENE TAPE IN
FRONT OF MY OWN HOUSE AND
VIRTUALLY MY DAUGHTERS, THEY
WERE CHAMPS AND SMART AND
EVERYBODY IS OKAY.
>> Greg: THAT IS GOOD, THAT IS
GOOD!
[APPLAUSE]
BEFORE I MOVE ON, ANY TRUTH TO
THE RUMOR THAT KATHY HOGLE WAS
SEEN SPEEDING AWAY?
>> Lee: ABSOLUTELY SO, WE ARE
STILL WAITING FOR CONFIRMATION.
>> Greg: JUST SCREAMING, IT'S
THE SHOTS!
ANYWAY, I'M GLAD YOU'RE HERE
TONIGHT, WE'LL TALK MORE ABOUT
CRIME AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COMMENT ON MY MONOLOGUE ARE JUST
BE HAPPY THAT I AM NOT ASKING
YOU ANYTHING?
>> Lee: YOU ARE NOW THE NEW
KING OF LATE NIGHT.
>> Greg: THAT IS TRUE.
AND THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GO AFTER YOU WITH BETTER
TALENT, THEY ARE NOT FUNNIER.
SO THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO TRY
IS TO FIND SOME ANGLE TO TAKE
DOWN THE KING.
THERE'S ANOTHER THEORY BY THE
WAY THAT MAYBE SUCCESS HAS GONE
TO YOUR HEAD SO MUCH.
THAT YOU HAVE RAISED YOUR
STANDARDS SO HIGH THAT IT HAS
BEEN LEFT WITH THIS CRITICISM OF
ALL THESE PEOPLE WHO USE THE
LOOK SO BEAUTIFUL.
>> Greg: BUT THEY DON'T
ANYMORE BECAUSE I AM SUCH A
SUPERSTAR MY STANDARDS HAVE JUST
JUMPED.
>> Lee: EXACTLY RIGHT.
SPEETWO YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT,
I FIND YOU HIDEOUS.
[LAUGHTER]
LYDIA.
>> YOU HAVE SIMPLE TASTES, YOU
ARE ALWAYS SATISFIED WITH THE
BEST.
>> Greg: THAT IS TRUE, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS, BUT YES,
MY STANDARDS WILL DROP OVER
TIME, OUR COLLEGE KIDS UGLIER
NOW, DO YOU AGREE WITH ME?
>> Lydia: YOU MENTIONED THAT
YOU DID NOT HAVE TIME TO DO THE
RESEARCH, SO I DID IT FOR YOU.
THIS IS FROM THE FEDERAL RESERVE
OF ST. LOUIS, THEY FOUND THAT
GOOD-LOOKING PEOPLE MAKE 5% MORE
THAN AVERAGE LOOKING PEOPLE,
UNATTRACTIVE PEOPLE MADE 9%
LESS, SO I THINK THERE IS
ACTUALLY AN ARGUMENT TO BE SAID
THAT IF YOU HAVE A QUARTER
MILLION DUCKS, YOU ARE BETTER
OFF SPENDING THAT ON REALLY GOOD
PLASTIC SURGERY THAN A FOUR YEAR
DEGREE FROM NYU.
>> Greg: THAT IS A GREAT
POINT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Lydia: I ALSO THINK
COLLEGES ARE GOING TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE, STRESS, IT'S A VERY
STRESSFUL TIME WHEN YOU ARE IN
COLLEGE, YOU'RE CRAMMING FOR
EXAMS AND STRESS LEADS TO WEIGHT
GAIN, YOU BREAK OUT, YOU LOOK
TIRED, AND COLLEGES ARE TRYING
TO MAKE IT LESS STRESSFUL.
AND WHY YOU FIRED UP A CHEMISTRY
PROFESSOR LAST WEEK, HIS CLASS
WAS TOO HARD, AT UT AUSTIN ONE
PROFESSOR IS NOT ASSIGNING
GRADES, HE'S NOT GOING TO TAKE
ATTENDANCE, SO I THINK THAT THEY
WILL HAVE TIME TO HIT THE GYM.
>> Greg: FINALLY.
>> WITH THE FRESHMAN 15 COMING
YOU CAN LOSE 15.
>> Lydia: NEGATIVE 15.
>> Greg: CHARLIE, YOU ARE A
JOURNALIST, BUT YOU ARE
HANDSOME.
[LAUGHTER]
WHY IS EVERYBODY IN YOUR TRADE
SO HIDEOUSLY UGLY?
EXCEPT FOR YOU.
>> Charlie: YEAH.
>> Greg: IS IT HEALTHY LIVING?
A >> Charlie: I CAN'T ANSWER
THAT, IT IS A REAL CURIOSITY.
IT ALWAYS HAS BEEN.
>> Greg: WE ARE ALWAYS
SURPRISED, BECAUSE OF JOURNALIST
WE HAVE ON OUR JUST HORRIBLE
LOOKING.
THE AMOUNT OF MAKEUP THAT WE GO
THROUGH ON SPECIAL REPORTS
ESPECIALLY.
>> Charlie: CAN WE TALK ABOUT
YOU?
>> Greg: YES.
>> Charlie: 58, I THINK IT'S A
JUST FOR THEM TO FOCUS ON THAT,
THE SECOND THING IS I THINK
THAT -- AND I THINK THAT LEE IS
RIGHT, YOU'RE THE KING OF LATE
NIGHT, BUT YOU ARE ALREADY
TRYING TO AGED OUT, THEY ARE
TRYING TO PUSH YOU TOWARDS 65.
>> Greg: I DID NOT THINK OF
THAT.
>> Charlie: THEY HAVE ACCEPTED
THAT YOU ARE HERE AND THERE'S
NOTHING YOU CAN DO ABOUT IT, SO
ALL THEY CAN HOPE IS THAT YOU
GET TOO OLD AND YOU HAVE TO
RETIRE.
>> Greg: WOW.
A >> Charlie: BUT YOUR POINT
AS A GREAT ABOUT COLLEGE.
AND YOU KNOW, MY PERSONAL BELIEF
IS THAT I THINK THAT
SOCIAL MEDIA HAS DESTROYED
COLLEGE.
BECAUSE IT USED TO BE WHEN YOU
ARE 18 COMING WENT TO COLLEGE,
IT WAS THE FIRST TIME YOU ARE
UNSUPERVISED, YOU ARE AROUND ALL
OF THESE PEOPLE WHO WERE YOUR
AGE AND AS RECKLESS AS YOU WILL,
AND IT WAS SO MUCH FUN.
BUT BECAUSE OF EVERYBODY IS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, THIS IS NOT
ANYTHING NEW TO THEM, AND THEY
GO TO COLLEGE, AND THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO PICK UP A GIRL AT A
BAR.
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO TALK
TO A GIRL AT A BAR.
>> Greg: EVERY THING IS
TWO-DIMENSIONAL,
THREE-DIMENSIONAL IS
FRIGHTENING.
>> Charlie: IT'S IN THEIR
STUPID PHONE.
>> Greg: THEY SHOULD BAR IS
WHERE NOBODY TALKS COMING TO
JUST TEXT EACH OTHER LIKE THIS.
>> Charlie: IT'S A HOT SPOT.
WHAT'S THAT THING CALLED?
>> Kat: INTERNET?
>> Greg: GIVE HIM A BREAK, HE
IS 75.
CHARLIE HURT, WE REMEMBER HIM AT
THE BAR!
QUITE THE JOURNALIST CAT, YOU
ARE A REPORTER FOR CAMPUS
REFORM, WERE YOU UGLY BACK THEN?
>> Kat: I WAS LESS ATTRACTIVE,
BUT THAT'S JUST BECAUSE I WAS
MAKING LESS MONEY.
I DID NOT KNOW ABOUT LIKE FOR
KAREN STUFF YET.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU MAKE MY
THEORY?
>> Kat: YOU DID A WHOLE
MONOLOGUE OF HOW GOOD-LOOKING
YOU ARE AND YOU ARE ASKING ME TO
COMMENT ON IT?
I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU WANT ME
OPINION, BECAUSE OF I'M GOING TO
BELIEVE EVERYTHING THAT I READ
ABOUT YOU ON THE INTERNET IN THE
PAST FEW DAYS, AND WAY TOO OLD
FOR YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
>> Kat: I DON'T KNOW IF I AM
ABLE TO TELL IF SOMEONE IS HOT
OR NOT.
I THINK I KNOW, BUT ACCORDING TO
MY FRIENDS I DON'T.
>> Greg: HAVE SEEN SOME OF THE
PEOPLE YOU UPDATED.
>> TO ME THEY WERE ALL HOT.
>> Greg: THEY ARE TROLLS.
YOU JUST MUST GO HANG OUT BY
BRIDGES.